[Music]
hey guys
it's quinn here as always if you
appreciate my content you can help out
tremendously
just by clicking the like button so that
the youtube algorithm realizes that i
actually uploaded a video
thanks guys from the start the dune saga
involves many moving pieces
there are countless factions vying for
power and specializing in very unique
and specific ways
if you are somewhat familiar with dune
lore then you know that many of these
factions arose in the vacuum that was
created after the butlerian jihad
the time in which a crusade was led
against thinking machines and all
computing devices were expunged from the
human universe
before this time human beings have used
thinking machines for just about
everything including space travel but in
becoming dependent upon machines
they unknowingly made themselves
subservient to those who were in control
of those machines
once men turned their thinking over to
machines
and the hope that this would set them
free but that only permitted other men
with machines to enslave them
thou shalt not make a machine in the
likeness of a human mind hall quoted
right out of the butlerian jihad and the
orange catholic bible
she said the ban on thinking machines
was extremely strict no form of
computing technology was permitted
no matter how rudimentary the punishment
for owning or producing such technology
was officially death due to the
butlerian jihad human beings had to find
new ways
to fill the void that computers left and
that is where our unique and specialized
factions come in
the first are the mintats human beings
capable of incredible
technical computations within their own
minds
most of the great houses of the landsrad
employed mintats
especially for tactical and militaristic
reasons
mintat training began at birth the
subject could not know of the training
for it would inhibit development
the main character of the first doom
book paul latreidis
discovers early on in the book that he
has also been trained as a mint hat
your mother wanted me to be the one to
tell you son you see
you have mintat capabilities paul stared
at his father
unable to speak for a moment then a mint
at
me but i how it agrees son
it's true but i thought mintant training
had to start during
infancy and the subject couldn't be told
because it might inhibit the early
he broke off all his past circumstances
coming to focus
and one flashing computation i see
he said the guild is another example of
a specialized
group which arose after the butlerian
jihad
out of all the groups the guild is the
most essential to the survival of the
galactic human empire
the guild through the use of great
amounts of the spice melange
mutate human beings until they are
capable of developing limited prescience
this limited prescience allows them to
navigate through the hazards of space
in the time before the butlerian jihad
computational devices
would have allowed ships to avoid
objects in the universe
the holtzman drives present and guild
highliners can fold space without the
use of spice melange
but without navigation this is extremely
dangerous
in the dark days before the guild but
after the butlerian jihad
one in every ten ships that traveled
through folded space
was lost the guild was extremely
influential in the dune universe
for they control the flow of all
commerce in the universe
their monopoly on space travel would not
be challenged for thousands of years
humankind's transition from projectile
type weapons to hand-to-hand combat
was influenced by but not directly
related to the butlerian jihad
because of the invention of holtzman
shields conventional weapons were less
used because they were much less
effective against such devices
and lasegun type weapons had devastating
effects
when they come in contact with shields
the reaction was always nuclear
because of this the genus school came to
prominence
the jenna's school trained the greatest
swords masters in the universe
in the beginning of the first book
duncan idaho is a swordsmaster of the
genus
employed by the great house of tradies
there were other specialized schools as
well
such as the souq school whose doctors
were trusted widely throughout the
universe
due to the fact that they were
conditioned against doing harm
the telalaksu are another interesting
faction they specialize in biological
technology
because of their extreme xenophobia and
isolation
they look very different from normal
humans
by the use of their axolotl tanks they
are able to create golus
essentially clones and they are also
capable of various other feats of
biological engineering
many of which repulse others in the
universe the chile laksu have a
reputation for being devious
and deceptive as well though their
technology
is utilized throughout the universe they
themselves do not wield very much
political power
in terms of the imperium as a whole
out of all of the factions in dune
however perhaps the most intriguing i
think are the bini jesuit
a matriarchal order who seeks to shape
the human universe
in an image that they themselves have
designed
the great revolt took away a crutch she
said it forced human minds to develop
schools were started to train human
talents the benny jesuit schools
she nodded we have two chief survivors
of those ancient schools
the bini jesuit and the spacing guild
the guild
so we think emphasizes almost pure
mathematics
the bini jesuit performs another
function politics
he said at the start of the series the
benny jesuit sisterhood moves only in
the shadows
they work mainly in the background of
galactic politics
presenting themselves in the guise of a
religious organization
the bini jesuit have incredible mental
abilities and are trained to observe the
most minor details
and control their internal chemistry on
a cellular level
they have a deep understanding of human
psychology and behavior
which allows them to easily manipulate
those around them and infiltrate nearly
every corner of the human universe
through matchmaking they are able to
breathe the noble houses of the lands
rat as they see fit
granting them enormous power in the
later books in the doomed series the
sisterhood eventually
emerges as one of the main leaders of
the human universe
it is arguable that the beni jesuit
secrets and manipulating tactics have
affected the outcome of human events
as much as perhaps even the guild
the sisterhood is also the only group
that maintains
its power throughout the entire original
dune series
which spans over the course of five
thousand years
essentially control of the dune imperium
is never in the hands of a single
faction or group
at least not until god emperor of dune
various groups will power at different
times
which is actually quite realistic frank
herbert wrote the doom saga to explore
concepts relating to human politics and
behavior
the future setting allows us to separate
ourselves enough from the story
that we can ultimately recognize how the
society which appears in the dune
universe
reflects our own thank you guys so much
for watching make sure you like and
subscribe for more quinn's ideas
[Music]